hello and welcome to this video I'm
irritated thereafter xsplit updated here
now I'm the whole thing is just slow
earlier typical yeah you hit the local
recording nothing happens there like for
10 seconds bit strange okay let's play
against grandmaster rude young zone and
what is he going for you three then i
have my age 5 line available nope the
light has various often see a d3 based
stuff III deform or possible 96 is of
course also an option but i have a soft
spot for putting the night on e 7 why
would you do that okay I would never
remotely think of playing me for with
the bishop being on a seven so reduced
it strange now a black should be fine I
control deform with h three bean plates
you probably don't want to play Bishop
to e3 now I can actually even take their
ok
sure about this but let's let's play it
the position is fine for black anyway
but I not quite sure what's what the
right move order is for example let's do
this i'm not sure i mean i don't have to
take that but i think this position is
just quite comfortable and I never even
I never get the move right yeah i was
thinking see if I this is correct but ok
I want to go change for words that's the
point
thanks Clayton by the way to x over the
board i think two or three times not
quite sure i'm sure of two and maybe
three times or jaws so the Queen now has
to go somewhere somewhere stupid
ok
yeah he has to try to get rid of her my
bishop here to see doing it I don't
really understand anything cannot take
bishop a three I mean I put my bishop
one key for what really that's great for
black I just start to take stuff now
okay this doesn't work then you're not
thinking concretely enough
if i take it takes before so we should i
should mention that so I cannot just
grab you six yeah he tries to play f4
let's clear it I'm not going to allow it
I'm a structural point of view white is
just lost I mean unless there's
something very concrete happening i'm
picking up e cigs and then I'm just
tearing them apart and we define their
for being so weak yeah maybe if I now
take here I can also take first down
let's do it and it's probably the
simplest way just get get the bone and
be happy with it so what now can you
play h5 just going going for this for
the kill them I wonder I cannot take six
pack and I can just play with the eight
or something cover it
I'm not sure about this very neat your
check here because I mean whether this
pawn one takes it too heavily never get
a move so put pressure on f2 this now
can be neatly covered with look at six
that's even active so if if all looks
good or maybe this is rushed rookie 325
yeah it's maybe not not so clear I can
do this though infiltrate here you can
take this now that the ending is really
bad that was my idea get the Queen to f4
time your ear
okay okay basically have to take can I
do this loop g6 is also on I don't wind
the house immediately I can take more
pawns check
let's use the king check now we should
see AIDS is not solving this in the long
run check check point with Alex ok so
let's have a look that I really didn't
get many decisions there ok so I think
if I was just wrong sorry that's a
strategic mistake you shouldn't weaken
the d4 square just like that against
this bishop I mean this is I didn't make
much sense to me and I had ff5
immediately gentium I wasn't sure about
about this and he I definitely expected
see takes d5 to have at least a sea pony
as a sorry 37 corn as a long-term target
ok 95 we should have fired and all looks
very normal and kiss this looks
difficult already I feel 96 sad the
engine is really versatile saying that's
true this is this is looking very strong
and threatening on on a 3 now here
already
and then he cannot take this this is not
going to work threatening everything
there check check that's a funny line
okay I took it because I felt I'm just
winning the pole which is also true yeah
there were alternatives but i think it
was it was fine basically you can do
other things therefore was of course the
principal move but I wasn't totally sure
what I should do here I had justified of
course at stupid d 5 is an easy move
some somehow I didn't see it then I have
the pawn why does not completely
completely tied down I have 26 or 25 4
10pm ya later today he's even know okay
after okay still I'm still fight or
Bishop d3 was better yeah I was
basically seeing the swimming ending and
didn't check didn't look much further
yeah these pawns are just to put cannot
cannot stop this ya think there was any
any any blunder or so or white wings
wide wins oh my god okay I didn't have
much time but so I have to start with
this move of course you cannot even
approach I just promote so this be three
and a six wins for this losers
he's just too quick oh my god all I was
too quick yeah no I'm just in time okay
I just instinctively push those and I
didn't really look at all yeah well this
is this is pretty clean yeah I'm just
promoting here and if I get two chicks
and first year this is will also promote
wow I almost lucky okay thanks for
watching